[Applause]
and finally new rule liberals must stop
chasing conservatives out of restaurants
they've done it to sarah huckabee
sanders they've done it to kirsten
nielsen they've done it to stephen
miller
and last monday it happened again when
ted cruz and his wife went out to dinner
and were bombarded by a chant of we
believe survivors
so i'm guessing the restaurant was
chipotle
but this is the new deal conservatives
get to run america and we get to ruin
their dinner
and listen i get it nobody wants to see
ted cruz when they're eating
ted cruz is what baseball thinks about
when it's trying not to come
but we need to get people like ted cruz
out of
power not out of restaurants
this is something republicans understand
way better than democrats that real
power
isn't about making a scene or what makes
you feel good
and power it's a lot like owning rabbits
the more you have
the easier it is to get a lot more
power begets power texas
has very similar demographics to
california but one reason they're red
and we're blue is we want every citizen
to be able to vote and they don't
a federal court has ruled seven times
the texas republicans
drew their congressional districts with
racial
discriminatory intent but our federal
court won't have the final say on this
that's the supreme court they will
which is why republicans so desperately
want to get schlitz kavanaugh confirmed
even though he doesn't have the
temperament to be a judge on american
idol
because like the rabbits the more
justices republicans get to pick the
more
those justices protect unlimited
campaign spending
and voter suppression laws which helps
more republicans get elected
power begets power
trump loves to say the system is rigged
yeah it's rigged your president
he leaves out the part that it's rigged
for them
the electoral college helps republicans
the fact that every state
gets two senators helps republicans mike
enzi of wyoming represents 287 thousand
people
kamala harris represents 20 million
why is wyoming even a state
there's not even a river or any other
kind of natural border separating it
from the other
square states it's just a square
it's like they copy-pasted colorado and
then forgot to put people in it
i know i've asked this before but
do we really need two dakotas
it's like when there's a starbucks right
across the street from another starbucks
it's greedy you're greedy dakotas for
senators for you it's like a little
person going up to the buffet and taking
half the food
[Laughter]
we all failed to notice that as more
americans moved to coastal cities in
pursuit of high-paying jobs as uber
drivers
rural red states became over-represented
which is why every election year we have
to hear what's on the mind of everyone
in a diner in iowa
meanwhile nobody ever talks to the loser
at the coffee bean in west hollywood
does america's vast army of unemployed
screenwriters not count
[Applause]
the constitution is not on our side
bush ii and trump both lost the popular
vote
they shouldn't be picking supreme court
justices
at all had the democrats
had the democrats who actually won the
popular vote
been in the oval office we'd now have a
seven to two
liberal majority on the court instead
as usual we all had to pin our hopes
this week on senator susan collins of
maine
population stephen king two lobsters and
a bear
[Applause]
[Laughter]
uh
when the deck is this stacked against
you
and the other party cheats
democrats have no margin for error or
[ __ ] you know who you are or
complacency
republicans in texas were able to draw
those districts with
racially discriminatory intent because
they won the state house
democrats lost a thousand state
legislature seats
in the last 10 years can't do it we just
can't do it like that
we need to win elections so we can
protect voting rights
so we can win elections next month
next month there is a referendum on the
ballot in florida
the state that so often decides our
elections to restore
the voting rights of 1.4 million
ex-felons who currently cannot vote
it could turn florida blue which turns
america blue
so next time you want to scream at a
politician
move to florida and help change that law
because
power begets power and we got to beget
some for ourselves